- [Instructor] A student
builds a circuit with a battery
and two resistors in series.
The resistance of R2 is
double the resistance of R1.
Below is the graph of the
energy lost at R1 over time.
So that's this graph.
Which of the following shows
the energy lost at R2 over time
in terms of E1.
We have these four choices here.
So pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own.
All right, now let's do this together.
So first let's visualize the circuit.
So you have your voltage source,
this is our battery here, so
this is the positive terminal,
negative terminal, and
then this could be our
first resistor, and then
that's our second resistor.
They tell us these two
resistors are in series
and we complete the circuit here.
This is going to be R1, this is R2,
and then if you just have
one circuit like this,
where you don't have any parts
of it that are in parallel,
your current throughout this circuit
is going to be constant.
So we could say at any point here,
our current, let's just call that I.
Now they tell us how do these resistances
relate to each other.
If R1 has a resistance
of, let's call it X ohms,
they tell us that the
resistance of R2 is double
the resistance of R1.
So this is X ohms, this
is going to be two X ohms.
And then to think about, what would be,
if this is the energy
dissipated across R1 over time,
to think about the energy
dissipated across R2 over time,
let's think about power and energy
and what we know about them.
So we know that power is equal
to energy dissipated over time.
So we could write, for
example, power is equal
to energy dissipated over time,
which can be expressed
as your change in voltage
across a resistor times the current
going through that resistor.
And so if you want an
expression for energy dissipated
over time, you can look at
this part, right over there.
We can just multiply
both sides by delta T.
And so we could write that
energy dissipated over time
is going to be equal to
our change in voltage
across the resistor times the current
going through the resistor,
times our change in time.
Now, if we are starting
at time equals zero,
our change in time is
just going to be whatever
time we are at minus
zero, so it's going to be
whatever time we're at,
so I'm just gonna write
times T right over here.
Now your change in
voltage across a resistor
we have learned before,
your change in voltage
across a resistor is just going to be
the current going through that resistor
times the resistance.
So we could take this and
substitute it back for
delta V, and what do we get?
We get energy dissipated
is going to be equal
to our current going through a resistor
times the resistance times
the current going through
the resistor times time, or we could write
that energy dissipated as a function of,
well as a function of all
three of these things,
is going to be the current squared
times the resistance times time.
Now, we already know
from this that at time T1
we have an energy dissipated of E1,
and that's what the resistance of X ohms.
So we can say we have
energy dissipated of E1
is equal to I squared times X ohms,
that's the resistance, times T1.
But now let's think about
what the energy dissipated
at time T sub one for our
second resistor would be.
At the energy dissipated,
if we just go back
to this equation right over here,
is going to be equal to T
sub one times our current,
remember we have the same
current going through
both resistors, they're in series,
so we have the same
current there, I squared,
and then what is going
to be the resistance?
Well instead of an X,
we have a two X here.
And so we can rewrite
this, we could rewrite this
as two time I squared times X times T1.
Well, this right over
here is the same thing
as the amount of energy
dissipated at time T sub one
in our first resistor.
So this is E sub one.
So at time T sub one,
the energy dissipated
and our second resistor
is going to be twice
as much energy.
And so what we wanna look
at is at time T sub one
we wanna have twice as much energy.
This dissipated, this
only has a fourth as much,
so we rule that out, this has half as much
energy dissipated, rule that out.
This has the same amount
of energy dissipated,
we rule that out, but then here,
at time T sub one, we have
dissipated twice as much energy.
So we like that choice right over there.
Another way to think about it is,
if you have the same current
going through two resistors,
and the second resistor
has twice the resistance,
and any given amount of time
for the second resistor,
you're going to dissipate
twice as much energy.
Another way to think about
it, you'll have twice
the slope of this line.
So this one right over here
clearly has twice the slope
of this, or you could say
for any given amount of time,
so from time equals zero to T sub one,
you would dissipate twice as much energy.
So instead of E sub one,
you would dissipate two times E sub one.